an illegal road cuts through what used
to be pristine rainforest
around it a cemetery of centuries old
trees reduced to dust
look those are big patches and most
likely for cocoa fields or cattle
ranching which will definitely
disconnect this area
rodrigo botero runs an ngo that protects
the colombian amazon he brought us on a
five-hour long flight across five
national parks and supposedly protected
indigenous lands
none are intact criminal hands are
grabbing land and burning trees for
intensive agriculture cattle ranching or
coca farming
the magnitude and the intensity of the
destruction that we are able to see over
five national parks in the most
biodiverse area of colombia in the
middle of the fragile transition between
the andes and the amazon is a warning
call not only for colombia but for
humanity as a whole the colombian amazon
has lost over a million hectares of
rainforest in the last five years an
area larger than the island of cyprus
rodrigo says a complex web of interests
are to blame
first of all this has to do with the
international conglomerates interested
in cheap land for the world's
agro-commodities market
more than a million heads of cattle have
been introduced in this area surrounding
the chiribiquete national park alone it
is also a way to launder money from drug
trafficking and illegal mining
the level of deforestation accelerated
after the government signed a peace deal
with farc rebels in 2006.
today huge branches extend for as far as
the eye can see one of the first things
you notice as you walk through these
burnt patches of the jungle is the
silence gone are the sounds of the
animals the birds the insects that live
in the forest all that amazing
biodiversity
turned into ashes
colombian president ivan duque pledged
to cut deforestation by half by the end
of his term in august an overtly
optimistic promise
yet a military anti-deforestation
initiative and new laws targeting those
causing environmental devastation are
starting to pay dividends
the first years of this operation have
been questionable because the military
exclusively went after the poor people
logging and not the masterminds we also
had an outdated legal framework because
believe it or not grabbing land wasn't a
crime here but under pressure
internationally things have started to
change in recent months a major land
grabber and two local mayors were
arrested
changes that offer a glimmer of hope
that things could improve before it's
too late for all alessandra ampietti al
jazeera san jose